ce serait trop suspect de passer la
sécurité de l'aéroport sans bagage juste
avec notre trophée dans mm se seraient
pas encore plus suspect passer la
sécurité avec des valises vides à
l'exception d'un pauvre petit trophée
oui il nous faut d'autres trop fait ça
va être ça le truc avec des bonnes
femmes qui vont et viennent avec tous
leurs prix avec l on ait connu le genre
star quoi on a gagné d'étape prix voilà
meilleur petit fils oui
grossman nerveuse on se fait reprendre
quand on a l'air mal à l'aise bonjour
vous êtes nouveau gm l'habitude de voir
césar les retombées se débarrasser nos
téléphones iphone vous trace et même
s'ils souhaitent un orphée vrai c'est le
genre de truc que je devrais savoir
parce que j'ai fait un stage avec edward
snowdon à la corde a essayé de faire ce
nom d'anne non non lui il a essayé à oui
je l'obsédait totalement il était hyper
fan de ce qu'a d'ailleurs quand on s'est
mis à parler autant de lui je me suis
demandé pourquoi il disait pas que
c'était un fan de ska fils ton téléphone
pfff tu as un pétard
dans quelques instants quelqu'un va pas
tarder à tirer ils veulent ce que vous
avez et ils vont tous nous massacrer
jusqu'à ce qu'il est
[Musique]
au maroc on fait quoi on va pas rester
là toute la soirée c'est ton
anniversaire
j'ai 30 ans je bosse en chemise
hawaïenne et mon petit copain m'a largué
pas fixe toro fait graver ses affaires
on voudrait vous parlez de brousse
ailleurs c'est bien votre petite amie de
brouille
pardon il est cool
je sais que tu es un espion c'est une
longue histoire je vais tout expliquer
y'a quoi sur ton front
il ya des salles du bas vrai moi et je
cherche pour ce faucon et ce paquet à
vienne où des tas de gens vont mourir tu
veux mourir sans avoir vu l'europe où tu
veux aller en europe et mourir en ayant
vu l'europe
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai que ces deux
options c'est vrai on millions
tout ça parce que tu te faisais un
espion tend les bras
un groupe de terroristes projet toute
une série d'assassinats plein
d'innocents vont mourir si on ne
s'arrête pas et si on vous aider
surréaliste je dois reconnaître que je
suis
ma vieille tu es incroyable ils sont
[Applaudissements]
je
reconnaître que vous êtes doué c'est
parce que je suis une vraie tueuse au
jeudi
c'est un truc de dingue tu t'es déjà
senti aussi vivant et cèdent pas mourir
hockey parce que je mourrais sans toit
et du coup on serait morte le 10 12
c'est pas vrai seigneur jésus c'est
râlant mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
vous deux dans mon bureau quoi vous êtes
là big boss et vous n'avez pas sacrifier
nonce de féminité c'est la beyoncé des
services
n'avait-on mois